[Musique]
bienvenue dans toute franchise c'est
l'heure de l'interview avec ce soir
François Bayrou bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le président du MoDem maire de Pau
vous êtes également en charge du Haut
commissariat au plan du Conseil national
de la refondation le président de la
République s'exprime demain à 20h on va
en parler pour dire quoi pour s'adresser
à qui il y a en particulier du travail
François Bayrou pour renouer le dialogue
avec les syndicats quand on voit ce que
dit dès ce matin Laurent Berger de la
CFDT dans Le Parisien Emmanuel Macron
n'a pas fait le choix de l'apaisement du
début à la fin c'est le mépris vous êtes
un soutien d'Emmanuel Macron que
répondez-vous à Laurent Berger
bon il y a une chose qui est certaine
des deux côtés c'est qu'il faut
réinventer la démocratie sociale en
France le une démocratie dans laquelle
chacun dans son rôle
les politiques à la fois du gouvernement
et
du Parlement qui soit de la majorité ou
de l'opposition et les syndicats dans la
vie du travail dans la vie
professionnelle il y a besoin de
réinventer ce
contact et je dirais cette confiance
mais aussi parce qu'il y a eu comme le
dire Laurent Berger du mépris dans ses
dernières semaines mais je crois que
chacun s'est enfermé dans son rôle avec
le sentiment qu'il n'avait pas de
répondant
et c'est vrai des deux côtés des deux
côtés il y a eu le sentiment que en
c'était un peu un dialogue de sourd les
uns disant ça sera comme ça et les
autres disons jamais et à ce moment-là
très difficile de trouver des avancées
donc vous connaissez que chacune des
deux parties a une part de
responsabilité oui je la liberté
de te reconnaître que qui a de la
responsabilité mais c'est une
responsabilité beaucoup plus large parce
que ce que je crois profondément va en
parler dans l'émission c'est que la
France ne sait pas comme beaucoup de
pays d'ailleurs occidentaux mais
peut-être plus encore chez nous parce
qu'on y est plus attaché ne sait pas ce
que démocratie veut dire qu'est-ce que
vous entendez par là
il dit la démocratie ce n'est pas que la
démocratie élective une fois tous les 5
ans ça se nourrit au jour le jour il a
raison et il a d'autant plus raison
qu'il est
représentatif d'un des grands courants
de la sensibilité française le courant
réformiste d'un courant auquel du côté
syndical il est naturellement légitime
et du côté politique nous sommes sur la
même sensibilité c'est pour ça que c'est
que c'est un peu triste qu'on n'est pas
réussi à nouer quelque chose mais
François il y a un exemple concret vous
faites le constat et vous partagez une
partie si je le comprends bien du
constat de Laurent Berger mais encore ce
week-end Laurent Berger il est aussi
meurtri blessé parce qu'il demande
vendredi soir solènement avec les autres
syndicats monsieur le Président de la
République ne promulguez pas la loi et
que la loi est promulguée dès vendredi
soir avec publications journal
officielle samedi est-ce que là ce n'est
pas une provocation du chef de l'État de
le faire si vite vous vous le faire ce
n'est pas une issue vous vous rendez
bien compte que demander de ne pas
promulguer ça veut dire être prêt à
reculer éventuellement
et donc mettez-vous à la place
de l'exécutif le président de la
République est pas tout seul après c'est
moi et c'est moi de d'affrontement de
débats d'une violence extrême
se retrouver en situation une fois que
le texte est adopté et validé par le
Conseil constitutionnel se retrouver en
situation de dire attendez peut-être un
peu encore c'est impossible ou peut-être
attendre quelques jours peut-être
attendre d'avoir repris l'angle avec ce
n'est pas
attendre comme Laurent Berger l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises c'est pas attendre
pour maintenir les choses en l'état
c'est attendre dans l'idée qu'on
pourrait changer or je trouve que de ce
point de vue là et c'est pour moi une
faiblesse de la situation actuelle
on se trouve on s'est trouvé où on a
laissé se faire se mettre en place une
impasse
je vais essayer je vais essayer de vous
dire pourquoi
parce que personne n'a réussi à
expliquer aux Français pourquoi cette
réforme était vitale vous aviez demandé
du temps pour cela
du temps mais aussi qu'on puisse
construire cette explication c'est
l'exécutif qui n'a pas fait c'est le
gouvernement
parti je suis pas là pour accuser les
uns ou les autres j'essaie on est là
pour dire les choses j'essaie de
comprendre ce qui se passe
pourquoi cette réforme est-elle vitale
pour deux raisons et qu'on n'a pas su
expliquer et pour moi c'est une grande
interrogation je ne sais pas pourquoi on
n'a pas voulu le certains l'ont compris
et ne sont pas d'accord non non vous
allez voir que que
ce n'est pas fondé que les désaccords ne
peuvent pas être maintenus que cette
impossible si on regarde la situation
pour deux raisons principales la
première de ces raisons c'est que du
point de vue de du financement des
retraites
on est dans une situation impossible pas
seulement demain comme beaucoup de gens
le disent comment l'a dit pendant le
débat mais aujourd'hui même
30% du financement des retraites n'est
pas assumée comme ça serait devrait être
le cas dans la répartition par les
actifs eux-mêmes c'est assumé par l'État
par le contribuable et sur ces 30% il y
a au moins 30 ou 40 milliards et je
répète chaque fois parce que le calcul
mental a disparu que 30 ou 40 milliards
ou 40000 millions d'euros tous les ans
j'entendais ces chiffres 30 000 millions
d'euros tous les ans qui sont pas
assumés par le système de retraite
lui-même et qui sont mis à la charge de
l'État et ceci est un est impossible est
insoutenable dans le temps mais ça vous
parle deuxièmement pas compris par
exemple n'a pas compris non je pense
qu'ils l'ont compris je pense que pour
eux c'est un peu plus difficile à
admettre et deuxièmement deuxièmement
ces dizaines de milliers de millions
d'euros
on ne les a pas
le budget de l'État ne les a pas donc il
les emprunte empruntent et donc ça fait
de la dette et donc ça revient à faire
payer les pensions des retraités
d'aujourd'hui par les actifs de demain
par les plus jeunes du pays et ceux-ci
c'est pour ça que je dis que pour moi en
réalité si on met cette ce phénomène ou
cette réalité devant les yeux il y a pas
une femme pas un homme pas une mère ou
un père de famille qui puisse accepter
l'idée qu'on fait payer les retraites
par ceux qui sont pas
si on se dit comme vous le dites que la
réforme était réellement indispensable
ça veut dire que le gouvernement une
présidente ils sont réellement mal pris
pour l'amener non pas suffisamment
correctement traité leurs interlocuteurs
peut-être même choyer presque j'ai envie
de dire leurs interlocuteurs pour les
embarquer avec eux non parce que vous
vous semblez résumer le débat de la
démocratie entre les responsables
politiques et les responsables syndicaux
c'est quand même et vous oubliez et vous
oubliez pour moi l'essentiel c'est à
dire les citoyens de base qui sont très
largement opposées aujourd'hui
personne ne leur a expliqué ce que je
vous dis et pourtant j'ai essayé comme
vous savez en mettant sur la table un
rapport du commissariat aux plans en
donnant les vrais chiffres dont vous
avez observé qu'ils n'ont été contredis
par personne personne même pas les
instances officielles chargés de mais
alors comment vous expliquez que ce
n'est pas été fait et que ce n'est pas
été compris nous ne nous avons à
réinventer
l'idée d'une démocratie nouvelle en
France et d'une démocratie vraie
qu'est-ce que c'est démocratie dans ma
bouche pourquoi j'emploie ce terme je
l'emploi au sens propre du terme et vous
savez que Un petit peu d'étymologie
ça veut dire la prise de responsabilité
donc aujourd'hui le pouvoir n'est pas au
peuple de votre point de vue non c'est
pas ça aucun pouvoir depuis des
décennies ne regardent les citoyens
comme des partenaires de la décision
on les regarde avec au fond le schéma
ancien dépassé qui consiste à dire
gouverner ses décider au sommet et
appliqués à la base pardon quand Marie
on devrait proposer cette réforme à
référendum c'est que vous avez déjà
entendu cette idée depuis 20 ans mais
c'est pas du tout de schéma qui a été
choisi c'est pas comme ça qu'on l'a
construit
mais ce sera un bon schéma mais je crois
que enfin si vous avez lu mais lui vous
aurez vous aurez retenu que j'ai
quatre ou cinq fois dans 4 ou 5 ouvrages
défendus cette idée parce que ça serait
empêcher les blocages mais on voit
encore aujourd'hui mais je me projette
sur l'avenir je regarde ce que nous
avons à faire nous avons à bâtir ce
rapport entre peuple et pouvoir dans
lesquels les pouvoirs acceptent ou
choisissent de partager avec les
citoyens les vrais raisons
parce que pourquoi on ne l'a pas fait
c'est ça une c'est ça une question
étrange pourquoi ne l'a-t-on pas fait ah
parce que c'est pas l'habitude de parce
que on a on a voulu probablement
préserver une certaine image d'équilibre
des finances publiques dans le pays et
parce que peut-être personne n'avait
regardé les chiffres mais aussi pardon
François peut-être parce que ce n'est
pas la conception d'exercice du pouvoir
du Président de la République
actuellement je ne suis pas d'accord
avec vous pour la raison que j'en ai
parlé vraiment 10 fois avec lui et que
je pense qu'il est assez proche de ce
que je pense mais c'est à lui de le dire
mais il le dira non en tout cas pour moi
en tout cas comme responsable politique
et même comme citoyen et comme et comme
quelqu'un qui a réfléchi beaucoup
à notre vie en commun depuis des années
qui s'étaient intéressé au problème de
la dette depuis déjà 15 ans qui s'est
intéressé
aux problèmes de la démocratie qui
comme citoyen je suis certain que
ceux-ci doit être pour nous une ligne
directrice alors François que nous avons
affaire c'est de sortir de ce système
d'affrontement est-ce que vous voyez
bien quand je dis l'idée qu'on décide en
haut et qu'on exécute en bas c'est un
affrontement entre le la base et le
prétendument
depuis des décennies en particulier
celui-ci vous avez vu les critiques sont
très perchées à l'adressées au président
de la République j'ai vécu comme ça le
privilège de l'expérience j'ai vécu
beaucoup de gouvernements et beaucoup de
réformes des retraites et chaque fois
des affrontements considérables autour
de cette idée de me souviens du du plan
Juppé autrefois sur les mêmes genres de
sujets et des difficultés qu'on
rencontrait et donc si nous voulons que
les choses changent encore faut-il
choisir des priorités et cette priorité
là changer le rapport entre le sommet et
la base de la société en considérant que
la base est partenaire du sommet et pas
obéissante pas sujet comme on disait
mais partenaire à ce moment-là
probablement nous allons trouver où nous
pouvons trouver un nouvel équilibre ça
doit être pour vous le sujet de la
locution du président de la République
demain il parle à 20h c'est pas vous qui
rédigez le texte très bien mais vous
êtes un citoyen un responsable politique
qu'est-ce qu'il vous paraîtrait être
utile demain ça doit être un des sujets
je pense que
il doit c'est normal je pense qu'il le
fera
dire ce qu'il a retenu de la séquence
de l'importance de ce texte et de la
manière dont la société française l'a
vécu et deuxièmement il doit ouvrir la
porte sur ce que seront
les buts à atteindre
le projet de société que nous avons à
défendre et à construire maintenant s'il
y a une critique à accepter c'est que
la campagne présidentielle n'a pas
traité de ces sujets principalement elle
a traité principalement du sujet des
retraites qui avait été isolé pour en
faire une sorte de contrat social mais
ça suffit pas
l'élection présidentielle c'est
l'élection d'un homme et cet homme porte
un projet pour l'avenir et je suis
persuadé que une nouvelle phase s'ouvre
qui au fond est
le deuxième acte de l'élection
présidentielle dans laquelle doivent
s'exprimer ce projet là
et là et la détermination et la volonté
du Président de la République
s'adressant au pays de de faire qu'un
certain nombre de sujets soient traités
mais ça veut dire qu'il doit d'une
certaine manière refaire campagne
représenter un projet repartir de zéro
oui parce que c'est comme en amour tout
est à reconstruire
constamment il n'y a pas de geste qui
soit plus vide de sens que l'habitude
que considérer que cette acquis
il y a tout à reconstruire dans la
relation et c'est toujours comme ça tout
au long donc là dans la race
mais de tous les quinquennat précédent
et on l'a bien vu au moment des gilets
jaunes par exemple c'était une séquence
de cet ordre il faut que de nouveau se
construisent que il faut que se
construise un nouvel acte quelque chose
qui puisse permettre de de regarder
l'avenir avec autre chose que de la
résignation donc un nouvel acte de la
relation entre Emmanuel Macron et les
Français et un nouvel acte de la
relation entre le pays et lui-même le
pays ces dirigeants aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans
la tête de tous ceux qui nous écoutent
il y a que bon on y arrivera jamais il y
a plus rien à faire
qu'au fond se heurte toujours au même
problème que on n'arrive pas à voir les
chances que nous avons la société
française c'est incroyable c'est une
société d'une d'une solidarité comme une
en existe aucune autre et je crois
qu'une capacité d'une inventivité des
inventeurs il y a il y a des créateurs
personne ne le voit on a l'impression
d'un pays où la résignation l'emporte et
autour de de cette résiliation ou au
bout de cette résignation il y a l'idée
que nous ne retrouverons jamais les
chances d'autres fois et moi je crois
exactement le contraire comment je crois
que tout ce que nous avons comme chance
on peut non seulement le faire renaître
mais le créer le faire naître parce que
ça fait des années qu'on traîne ses
boulets là il faut se débarrasser des
boulets comment on fait François Bayrou
pour se débarrasser de ses boul réussite
est-ce que c'est d'abord la priorité
apaiser le pays parce qu'il est fracturé
parce qu'il y a des tensions où est-ce
que c'est au contraire accéléré pour
réformer le plus vite possible hier à la
première ministre disait dans les
semaines moi qui viennent autour du
président nous sommes déterminés à
accélérer dans son entourage dans
l'entourage des présidents on dit pour
demain il s'agira de redonner du sens à
la réforme et d'enclencher sur la suite
bon est-ce qu'on peut faire les deux en
même temps est-ce qu'on peut apaiser et
accélérer à la fois est-ce qu'il ne faut
pas choisir je suis pas du tout sûr que
le mot accéléré soit soit exact soit le
bon voilà on ne peut éluder aucune des
questions qui se posent à la France et
aux Français la France comme pays dans
le monde comme modèle de société et les
Français comme foyer comme comme famille
ou préluder aucune des questions croyez
qu'on peut éluder la question de
l'éducation
tout le monde voit bien dans quelle
profondeur de crise nous sommes dans le
système éducatif la France qui était
considérée comme un des pays du monde
peut-être le pays du monde où
l'éducation était du plus haut niveau de
la plus haute qualité regardez les
établissements français à l'étranger par
exemple comme il suscitait et suscitent
encore de l'envie et nous sommes dans
une crise qui fait que nous sommes que
nous apparaisons comme incapable de
transmettre les fondamentaux mais ça
fait 6 ans qu'Emmanuel Macron est au
pouvoir oui mais ça fait pas que six ans
ça fait 30 ans que ces questions se
posent et qu'on n'arrive pas à les
traiter je crois parce que on n'a pas
pensé ce que pouvait être
la reconstitution de la volonté d'un
pays mais est-ce que ça peut servir aux
posons la question très simplement avec
l'équipe actuelle est-ce que ce que vous
êtes en train de dire n'est pas la
preuve la démonstration qu'il faut des
gens capés des hommes et des femmes
politiques qui connaissent le pays qui
l'ont pratiqué ce qui n'est peut-être
pas tout à fait la fiche d'identité du
gouvernement actuel chaque fois que vous
défendez l'expérience devant moi je vous
trouve sympathique donc
c'est pas
la définition de l'équipe et la
composition de l'équipe ça appartient au
président de la République je suis
souvent exprimé pour y compris à votre
micro pour dire que
l'équipe portait une volonté politique
devait porter une volonté politique mais
aujourd'hui laisser le président de la
République le Gouvernement et la
première ministre mettre au point leur
fiche de de poste si je puis dire vous
dites la première ministre parce qu'il
est acquis pour vous qu'elle a vocation
à rester c'est la décision du Président
de la République
rien n'est acquis mais il n'aime pas
changer aussi souvent que les
observateurs voudraient qu'ils le
fassent donc j'y vois un indice dans
votre réponse je me permets de faire les
sous-titres du fait qu'elle devrait
rester à Matignon et un changement de
pas prévu pourtant il y a certaines
personnalités compris des hommes
politiques d'importance il y a quelques
jours par exemple Jean-Pierre Raffarin
sur ce plateau l'ancien Premier ministre
qui disent il faut rentrer dans une
logique de cohabitation il faut
travailler avec les républicains parce
que pour faire avancer le pays il faut
une majorité que cette majorité elle est
avec la droite oui alors je lis ces
déclarations et
je trouve qu'elles sont
pas adaptés
n'est-ce pas cette majorité elle s'est
formée en 2017 le pacte politique c'est
un pacte qui s'est formé autour d'un
bloc central
et tous ceux qui perpétuellement ça
arrive régulièrement un peu comme comme
revient la grippe
dans une année qui vous disent faut
aller à gauche où il faut aller à droite
cela ne comprennent pas et d'une
certaine manière ni le pacte qui a été
scellé avec le pays en 2017 il faut
encore aujourd'hui pourquoi
c'est si on ne l'avait pas on irait vers
des
errements et des catastrophes gouverner
avec la droite c'est vraiment un
catastrophe non c'est pas ce que je suis
en train de dire ne me faites pas
tout à fait
que vous êtes habile et rusé mais là
j'essaie de dire des choses claires
si vous allez d'un côté ou de l'autre
vous fracturer le pays
le secret le
principe du bloc central que nous avons
construit c'est qu'il considère qu'on ne
doit pas fracturer le pays et que son
compatibles des
identités politiques différentes à
condition qu'il y ait une volonté
clairement exprimée et que cette volonté
respecte les uns et les autres on dit
alliance avec LR avec la droite comme
vous dites en tout cas avec la partie de
la droite gouvernementale mais ils ont
été élus dans l'opposition
croire qu'ils peuvent changer et passer
de l'opposition à la majorité à mon sens
c'est ne pas respecter les engagements
qui sont qui sont que des personnalités
puissent
accepter d'appartenir à des équipes
gouvernementales c'est de tous les temps
et c'est le jeu mais c'est pas ce qui ce
qui m'intéresse ce qui m'intéresse
profondément c'est que ceux qui dans le
pays se reconnaissent dans ces
sensibilités ne soient pas blessé ou
heurté parce que on leur arrache leur
identité et donc ça veut dire
Françoise on tente un coup d'avoir des
voix que la gauche un coup avec la
droite on coupe par coup parce que vous
voyez que vous retombez pardon
ce que je vais dire vous retombez
toujours dans la même ornière en moyenne
réalité parlementaire en croyant que la
politique du pays ça se fait
au sein du Parlement ou uniquement avec
les forces
identifiées comme étant institutionnel
les parties les syndicats mais c'est pas
ça le jeu où ça dépasse le gouverner le
pays en faisant fi la réalité
parlementaire aujourd'hui
convaincu le pays
adressez-vous à la société française
adressez-vous aux femmes et aux hommes à
ceux qui vivent la vie comme elle est
et trouver les mots et trouver les
accents qui peuvent leur permettre de se
reconnaître dans le mouvement que vous
avez lancé là vous n'aurez plus besoin
de faire ces intrigues de parties à
partir ça n'est pas comme ça que la
Cinquième République fonctionne la 5e
République c'est
la faculté de souder et d'entraîner les
Français autour de la proposition que
vous leur faites cité tout à l'heure
François Beraud Marine Le Pen ce qu'elle
était invité du Grand Jury sur LCI RTL
Figaro à la mi-journée elle dit très
simplement pour le président pour le
pays il y a trois manières de sortir du
conflit elle cite le référendum la
dissolution de l'Assemblée nationale la
démission du président de la République
elle leur recommande aucune elle ne dit
pas il doit faire ceci ou cela elle dit
c'est le constat que je fais est-ce que
la solution vous venez nous dire quelle
était votre vision de la politique passe
par l'un de ces trois instruments
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est des
instruments et on choisit de les
utiliser ou pas ces déclarations sont
vieilles comme le monde est comme la
Cinquième République ils en a on a
entendu ça vous et moi absolument 100
fois
mais réduire la crise politique dans
laquelle nous sommes à des jeux avec des
instruments comme ça c'est se tromper
sur la profondeur de ce qui se passe ce
qui se passe c'est une perte de
confiance profonde
qu'aucune manœuvre
ne résoudra si on ne touche pas au fond
si
on en parlait juste avant que l'émission
de comment se vous et moi la parole
politique c'est l'authenticité
si vous jouez si vous jouez avec des
instruments
si vous croyez qu'en appuyant sur tel
bouton vous allez obtenir telle réponse
en réalité vous passez à côté de la
vraie question qui est une question de
confiance est-ce que en ces hommes et
ces femmes nous citoyens nous avons
confiance mais est-ce que c'est et ça ne
peut pas se faire en utilisant des
leviers éculés ça ne peut pas se faire
par des recettes autre chose vous dites
par des recettes oui il y a à réinventer
la démocratie française pour que revivre
le modèle français il y a demain
François Bayrou quelques heures avant la
locution de président une réunion à
l'Élysée avec les principaux 4 de la
majorité à 15 heures vous y serez vous
le présent vous informera ce qu'il
entend dire ou c'est un sujet un lieu de
débat vous allez débattre de ce qu'il
faut faire pour le pays je sais pas bien
ce qu'il a l'intention de dire mais je
crois qu'en effet on va il a l'intention
qu'on que soit abordé la situation et je
ne dirais pas autre chose que ce que je
dis à votre micro un conseiller de
l'exécutif qui est cité ce matin par nos
confrères du Parisien dit à propos du
chef de l'État il a envie d'en découdre
est-ce que c'est aussi cet état d'esprit
que vous percevez son tempérament
personnel et plutôt mousquetaire comme
ça et plutôt rugby que que danse
classique dans le combat politique ce
n'est rien de le dire et donc et
d'ailleurs je me reconnais assez bien
dans dans cette manière d'être mais il
sait il ne peut pas ignorer que sa
responsabilité n'est pas d'être un
combattant dans le jeu politique sa
responsabilité est d'être le rassembleur
du jeu politique
et en tout cas à mes yeux si je peux
avoir être d'une certaine influence il
faut les deux il faut une dynamique et
une faculté de rassemblement mais quand
il dit ma devise c'est de ne rien lâcher
quand il le dit à Notre-Dame
est-ce que c'est le bon signe à envoyer
combien notre pays a souffert des gens
qui lâchaient
si vous regardez
le les problèmes qui se posent et la
date à laquelle on a commencé à les
poser
on disait tout à l'heure j'ai dû poser
le problème de la dette entre 2005 et
2007 parce que je voyais venir la
gravité des questions qui ne
manqueraient pas de se poser avec les
habitudes que l'on prenait tout le monde
a considéré que c'était
c'était pas grave c'était secondaire on
s'est trompé je suis persuadé de ça le
lorsqu'on a vu venir la question lorsque
j'ai souligné la question de la
privatisation des autoroutes qui revient
aujourd'hui constamment à grande guide
et contre laquelle contre laquelle je me
suis battu tout seul il y a plus de 15
ans et donc si on choisit une attitude
politique qui consiste à affronter les
questions tout en regardant à long terme
ce qui le travail de du commissariat aux
plans que j'ai que j'ai que j'exerce que
j'assume à ce moment-là les choses
changeraient on a cité plusieurs
questions on a parlé des retraites mais
il y en a d'autres la démographie vous
croyez qu'on va pouvoir vivre dans une
société française avec autant de
solidarité donc de besoin de financement
si on se trouve à ne plus avoir de
jeunes pour les porter ça n'existera pas
il n'y a pas de pays qui se projette
dans l'avenir si sa démographie
s'effondre qu'un grand problème c'est
pas qu'un problème politique c'est un
problème humain ça va malgré tout pardon
pas sûr d'avoir saisi comment on procède
en termes de gouvernance vous dites la
démocratie va falloir trouver de
nouvelles méthodes pas les instruments
éculés il y a un président de la
République en place qui ne reconnaît pas
d'erreur sauf celle de ne pas avoir
réussi à convaincre une première
ministre qui de ce que l'on comprend va
rester à son poste un gouvernement sur
lequel vous ne voulez pas vous prononcer
bon très bien qu'est-ce qui fera que
demain le pays sera mieux gouverné ou
avancera mieux que ce n'est le cas
aujourd'hui la volonté de l'exécutif des
gouvernants de poser devant les Français
en termes non ambigu les problèmes que
nous allons avoir à résoudre un discours
de vérité du sang et des larmes indice
je crois j'ai jamais cru au sang et aux
larmes je pense que si vous résolvez les
problèmes qui se posent à vous au
contraire vous choisissez que l'avenir
s'ouvre c'est quand il y a rien à faire
qui a du sang et des larmes mais c'est
pas du tout le cas est-ce que vous
croyez par exemple aux conventions
citoyenne il y en a une qui s'est réunie
sur la fin de vie qui a fait des
position est-ce que ça c'est un
instrument qui convient ou c'est un
instrument factice il y a probablement
des sujets sur lesquels ça convient mais
si l'on choisissait cette seule réponse
ça veut dire que le Parlement n'aurait
plus de sens
or il est très nécessaire de relégitimer
le Parlement de relégitimer les débats
qu'est-ce qui une des raisons pour
lesquelles ça va mal c'est que le
Parlement est bloqué mais de ce que
Parlement bloqué il peut continuer à
gouverner la loi d'abord le Parlement
est bloqué par sa propre faute par son
par sa désorganisation mais le si long
si l'on regarde ce que sont les
fonctions d'un parlement un parlement
c'est
la mise en évidence des débats du pays
des conflits du pays vous savez
autrefois quand on étudie le théâtre
grec on disait que le théâtre grec il
mettait sur les passions de la société
on appelait ça la purgation des passions
la catharsis et bien le Parlement c'est
la même chose aujourd'hui ce rôle n'est
pas tenu pourtant
que le que l'affrontement prend la place
de tous les débats et je pense qu'il
serait nécessaire qu'on retrouve des
débats un peu plus respectueux ce qu'un
certain nombre de forces politiques font
et valent il y a un sujet sur lequel
vous êtes beaucoup exprimé par le passé
c'est la question des institutions c'est
lié à notre discussion sur la démocratie
c'est un sujet que le président a évoqué
mais sur lequel il n'a jamais réussi à
avancer est-ce qu'aujourd'hui les
conditions sont réunies pour le faire ou
est-ce que le Parlement tel qu'on vient
de décrire là l'absence de majorité
absolue empêche toutes évolution sur ce
sujet je ne sais pas si les évolutions
sont possibles mais je sais qu'il est
nécessaire que le Président de la
République donne sa vision de l'avenir
des institutions et pas seulement lui
que les forces politiques
essaient de
de proposer dans les termes
compréhensibles par tout le monde ce que
nos nouvelles règles doivent être et je
crois qu'il y a qui a beaucoup à faire
de ce point de vue la priorité ce serait
quoi s'il devait choisir un instrument
pour le coup une évolution
institutionnelle c'est de stabiliser la
question de la loi électorale de la
représentation la proportionnelle oui
avec un choix il y a plusieurs sortes de
proportionnelle possible il faut dire
lequel est le bon les Allemands vivent
avec une proportionnelle qui permet de
faire à la fois
une élection à la circonscription et
avoir un résultat qui représente
réellement le pays et vous voyez que
c'est une démocratie beaucoup plus calme
c'est une démocratie qui est capable de
prendre des décisions je suis persuadé
que il y a aucune fatalité que la France
ne puisse pas le faire mais évidemment
ça veut dire que il faut éviter de se
laisser submerger par la vague des dn
parce que c'est ça qui se passe la vague
des haines qui dans nos institutions
prend aujourd'hui une place
beaucoup trop lourdes est-ce qu'il faut
François Bayrou aussi revoir selon vous
les règles qui est président
d'initiative partagée il y a un
RIB qui a été déposé devant le Conseil
constitutionnel qui n'a pas été validé
il y a une deuxième tentative de la part
de l'opposition mais en résumé les
oppositions disent de toute façon cet
instrument est très compliqué trop
compliqué et même s'il entendait s'il en
aboutissait il ne réglerait pas la
question cet instrument comme vous dites
ne peut pas être validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel aujourd'hui pourquoi
parce que la loi dit on peut faire un
référendum où on peut demander un
référendum de cette nature s'il y a
suffisamment de parlementaires pour
soutenir un texte pas la majorité mais
une partie des parlementaires et si
ensuite les citoyens signent pour ce
texte à une condition c'est qu'il ne
porte pas sur un texte qui a été adopté
depuis moins d'un an or le texte est
adopté là mais c'est peut-être la preuve
que justement cet instrument du rythme
n'est pas correctement écrit n'est pas
n'est pas utilisable par les citoyens
parce que si vous estimez que toute
délibération de l'Assemblée nationale et
du Sénat doit être soumise à référendum
il y a plus de Parlement
et ce n'est pas votre souhait il y a une
question françois Bayrou dans tout ce
qu'on dit là certes il va falloir que
chacun fasse des efforts et vous lancer
des messages ce soir aux formations
politiques à tous les acteurs du pays il
y a quand même la question du président
de la République on voit que la colère
le mécontentement c'est cristallisé
autour de sa personne il est allé sur
ces deux derniers mois quasiment 3
derniers mois seulement deux fois un
déplacement sur le terrain en France
est-ce qu'il doit aujourd'hui de votre
point de vue y retourner est-ce qu'il
doit reprendre un contact direct avec
les Français quitte à se mettre à porter
gif de baffe d'engue comme il a dit
lui-même parfois vous le connaissez
chaque fois qu'il s'est trouvé dans une
situation de blocage c'est sur le
terrain qu'il est allé chercher la
résolution de ces blocages il doit le
faire cette fois-ci au moment des gilets
jaunes il a fait le grand débat
c'est-à-dire pendant des dizaines
d'heures avec les Français les plus les
plus agressifs parfois
or c'est sa nature profonde donc je suis
persuadé que que cette force que c'est
forcément une une démarche qu'il
choisira parce que
vu de loin
on n'est pas ressenti comme on les de
près il y a de près dans le contact
personnel y compris à cause de vos
caméras qui sont là
il y a de près des sentiments qui
passent et vu de loin il n'y a que des
idées abstraites qui passent mais il y a
parfois eu aussi des formules
malheureuses peut-être un peu dures un
peu abruptes du chef de l'État lesquels
vous n'envoyez aucune non mais on cite
toujours traverser la rue vous trouverez
du travail il y a à Pau aujourd'hui deux
fois plus d'offres d'emploi que de
demande d'emploi
mais le problème c'est l'adéquation
entre un côté de la rue et l'autre côté
et donc je suis je sais qu'il avait ça
en tête et je rencontre pas un
entrepreneur peint un responsable de
recrutement qui ne me disent les
difficultés incroyables qu'il a à
trouver quelqu'un est-ce qu'on peut
parfois avoir raison sur le fond et tort
sur la forme oui est-ce que ça peut
arriver au chef de l'État à tout le
monde lui et à d'autres à tout le monde
c'est la démocratie vous savez bien
c'est un art subtil
c'est quelque chose qui touche
au sentiment
[Musique]
premièrement parce que les idées sont
incarnées pour exister dans le débat
faut que les idées aient un visage et il
est forcément comme il est le point le
plus haut de la pyramide il est ce
visage là
et malheureusement
le
ce monde des télévisions continuent et
des réseaux sociaux
attendant sa
aggraver les caricatures à caricaturer
il est un homme de 100 ans il devrait
pouvoir tenir compte de toutes ces
contraintes
c'est facile quand on est de votre côté
du micro
et vous le savez bien ce que vous vivez
j'ai pas fait le choix de votre carrière
en effet
mais se mettre au risque dans la tempête
prendre le vent de face et comme je le
disais la grêle c'est moins facile et on
est dans des temps ou être responsables
politiques et moins facile qu'autrefois
dans la manière de tendre la main est-ce
que ça ne nécessite pas aussi parfois de
la tendre au bon moment le président de
la République a fait savoir qu'il
souhaitait recevoir les syndicats à
l'Elysée mardi il s'est vu opposé une
fin de non-recevoir puisque les
syndicats disent pas question avant le
1er mai ils reprennent d'ailleurs à leur
compte une parole qui a vu la première
ministre l'idée qu'il dit tu vois y
avoir une période de convalescence
Laurent Berger dit même un délai de
décence pour le moment est-ce que vous
partager cette idée qu'il faut une
période de convalescence ou de dessin
alors j'ai lu attentivement l'interview
de Laurent Berger comme je lis souvent
ce qu'il écrit
Laurent Berger il ouvre une porte
pas immédiate
pas demain matin mais on est le 15 avril
et il parle d'après le premier mai
est-ce que enfin vous mesurez bien qu'on
n'est pas dans la dans la haine civile
je trouve que j'ai trouvé dans cette
interview que que bon la perspective
d'une reprise du dialogue ou des
dialogues le fait qu'il
désigne même des sujets sur lesquels il
faut travailler notamment les sujets de
la négociation en entreprise de la
démocratie sociale dans l'entreprise ont
été retoqués par le Conseil l'index
Seigneur le CDI seniors mais pas
seulement et donc donc ça prouve qu'il y
avait des choses bien dans le texte
et donc qui devait compenser
du point de vue du président de la
République et de sa volonté de pouvoir
renouer il y avait quelque chose
d'encourageant dans dans cet et dans
d'autres expressions parce qu'il y a
d'autres leaders syndicaux d'autres
syndicats qui ont des expressions de cet
ordre dans la manière de gouverner il y
a aussi une promesse qui a été faite par
la première ministre plus de 49,3 hors
texte budgétaires pour la suite du
quinquennat est-ce que c'est tenable
moi je comprends pas très bien ce je
comprends pas très bien la polémique qui
a eu autour du 49-3
et je
n'ose pas imaginer que dans l'avenir on
n'aura pas besoin de cette arme-là le
49.3
fait naître la Cinquième République
allié avec ceux qui ont vécu la fin de
la quatrième parce que ils avaient vécu
le drame de l'impuissance d'un parlement
tellement divisé que rien ne pouvait
passer et ils ont dit il faut qu'on
trouve quelque chose qui nous permette
de d'échapper à cette fatalité et ils
ont écrit ensemble quand on offre trois
d'ailleurs en réfléchissant à ce qui se
passait dans la République
de la République fédérale allemande j'ai
dit sur votre antenne ou dans ce studio
en tout cas à plusieurs reprises que bon
c'est une arme absolument légitime sur
le fond ça consiste à dire quelque chose
que qui est qui est simple un
gouvernement dit ce texte là
et vital pour l'idée que je me fais de
l'avenir du pays si vous le repoussez
alors je m'en vais ça que ça veut dire
le 49-3 et je trouve que c'est
absolument
adapté aux grands textes qui se pose et
on le sait bien au texte budgétaire
c'est autrement vous avez pas de budget
donc il y a plus de gouvernement il y
aura les autres textes il y a aussi une
question François bayrouz c'est celle de
l'exemplarité des élus de l'image des
élus et dégradés c'est pas les seuls
acteurs il y a beaucoup d'acteurs
institutionnels qui sont concernés par
cette défiance il y a quelques heures à
peine le tribunal correctionnel de
Marseille a condamné le maire de Toulon
monsieur Falco qui était Président
également de la métropole de Toulon pour
Russell de détournement de fonds publics
il va donc être contraint de renoncer à
ces modèles électifs ça fait partie des
peines qui sont prononcées à son
encontre
tout cela pour avoir entre autres eu des
déjeuners non payés qui étaient pris à
la cafétéria du conseil départemental
alors qu'il ne prise plus la
collectivité des dîners qui lui étaient
préparées par des personnels rémunérés
l'argent public et la mise à disposition
donc donc d'agent est-ce que vous dites
il a fauté donc il doit être sanctionné
ou est-ce que vous dites la justice va
trop loin dans ce qu'elle reproche aux
élus
vous avez oublié une partie essentielle
de cette affaire il y a un grand
principe de droit qui est le principe de
proportionnalité faut qu'il y ait
proportionnalité entre la peine et la
faute peine dure là parce que la
président du tribunal dit il y a un
devoir d'exemplarité des élus
il a déjeuné à la cafétéria du conseil
général qu'il présidait
avant d'être mère de Toulon bon est-ce
que c'est répréhensible bon
peut-être peut-être c'est pas recommandé
mais ça n'est pas un crime contre
l'humanité ça n'est pas une faute
que vous ne dites pas dans cette affaire
c'est que bon quand vous obligez un élu
à démissionner vous le condamnez à la
mort civile or c'est la seule peine sur
laquelle vous ne pouvez pas faire appel
le principe de proportionnalité il est
défendu par quoi par la possibilité de
chaque justiciable de faire appel d'une
décision qu'il trouve injuste prise sous
le coup de l'émotion ou quelquefois
excessive ça arrive tout le temps songer
au nombre de décisions qui ont été
réformés en appel et la seule qui soit
pas susceptible d'appel qui s'applique
comme un coup près
c'est cette décision là mais
bien monsieur Falco je connais rien à
cette affaire mais si ce qui est écrit
dans les journaux est vrai et si cet
homme réélu à 74% au premier tour à la
tête de sa mairie et déchu de ses
mandats simplement parce qu'il a déjeuné
à la cafétéria et je crois que la
présidente du tribunal j'ai dit dans le
même article que vous elle a dit que un
certain nombre de ses dépenses étaient
dérisoires
pour ces raisons dérisoires là
que la peine qu'on ne puisse qu'il ne
puisse pas faire appel et qu'il soit
frappé de mort civil vous savez que
quand vous êtes dans cette situation il
y a quelque chose d'extrêmement
enfin de terrible pour quelqu'un sans
pouvoir faire appel alors je trouve
qu'il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas
dans notre système judiciaire sur ces
sujets en quelques secondes pour
conclure François bayrout tout ce qu'on
s'est dit depuis le début de cette
entretien est-ce que comme Laurent
Berger ça vous fait dire que malgré tout
c'est le rassemblement national qui
risque d'être le grand vainqueur de
cette situation je ne conseille jamais
des succès à ceux avec qui je suis en un
seul en compétition mais en
contradiction je trouve que passer son
temps à faire la publicité de ses
concurrents ou de ses adversaires c'est
une très mauvaise stratégie et donc je
sais comment faire baisser le Front
national en posant
en termes francs et en résolvant les
problèmes du pays si vous êtes si les
Français ont le sentiment qu'il y a en
situation de responsabilité des femmes
et des hommes qui les comprennent qui
savent trouver les bons mots et qui ont
une vision claire de l'avenir alors ils
n'iront plus aux extrêmes merci beaucoup
François Bayrou d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce soir